we're gonna bring in Congresswoman Nancy
mace congresswoman thank you for being
with us I want your reaction to in
particular this chaos at the border and
the images and the videos we saw with
those uh that group of a thousand
migrants pushing toward that bridge
well it's unbelievable honestly to see
this kind of video our border is not
secure this is like you know secretary
mayorkas is like a firefighter running
away from a fire he ought to be
impeached for this and this lawlessness
has to end this is unbelievable they're
putting the lives of our border patrol
at risk here by allowing this kind of
thing to happen we're not following our
laws we allow them to come here
illegally and stay here illegally
without consequence and you're seeing
the results of that today but I think it
goes beyond that congresswoman based
upon this Wild video isn't it clear to
you that the message from this white
house is still hey come on over
come on over and hey if we're a Democrat
mayor we might even let you vote in our
Municipal elections because that's what
some democrat Mayors are trying to do
and this is wrong and secretary mayorkas
has buried his head in the sand and I
wish that we could impeach him for the
crappy job he's clearly doing about the
Border I want to get to this now the
president is set to address the nation
today on that banking system as the
signature bank is shut down following
the collapse of svb you know
congresswoman some people are calling it
a bailout some are not where do you
stand on it
well we're a little murky on the details
I would like to know how it's going to
be paid for specifically we were on a
call last night if you looked at svb's
latest public filing they had a healthy
balance sheet they had assets on the
books I'd like to know if an auction of
the bank is on the table I believe that
it that it may be there may be a way to
recruit some of that investment you know
we'll see as we learn more later on this
week Joe Biden releasing a statement
last night saying quote I am firmly
committed to holding those responsible
for this mess fully accountable that
seems like something that happens in the
coming days weeks and months for today
with the market set to open in about
three and a half hours what does Joe
Biden need to say before the markets
open to sort of calm the waters here a
bit
well he needs to instill confidence in
the market today needs to show
leadership so that there isn't a panic
run on Banks and get that message out
there I was encouraged to see a
statement by the FDIC Federal Federal
Reserve and the treasury yesterday
afternoon but he's got to instill
confidence in the market in order for
folks to stay calm and know that if you
are even if your deposits and svb were
over the FDIC insured 250 000 that
you're going to be okay and that's the
message that they need to hear today I
want to talk about this some lawmakers
are saying the Biden Administration has
plans for social media censorship a
campaign on this Bank collapse just
really quickly I want to read this the
tweet from Thomas Macy said just get off
of a zoom meeting with the FED treasury
FDIC House and Senate a Democrat Senator
essentially asked whether there was a
program in place to censor info on
social media they could lead to a run on
the banks you were in this meeting what
exactly what are they talking about here
right it was brought up during the zoom
call last night the idea that if the
administration was going to push for
censorship of certain media stories so
there's no run on the banks there should
be no censorship on the table whatsoever
in any way shape or form whether you
agree with the administration's position
or not we've seen this story before time
and time again and it's wrong and we've
got to make sure that our government is
not trying to censor information for
business owners individuals or the
public it seems to me that Dem certain
Dems a lot of Dems can't stop won't stop
when it comes to censorship it's almost
like they think the first amendment is
optional it is not Congresswoman Nancy
mace we thank you so very much for
joining us this morning on a very busy
news morning and breaking down these
complex issues thank you
I'm Steve Ducey I'm Brian Kilmeade and
I'm Ainsley Earhart and click here to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
to catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis